Alright, Sara, I made some CSS changes, how can I,
what's the best way to see what they look like?
>> Alright, so if we just open up the
HTML file, so this is in the, the main directory.
>> Uh-huh.
>> This index.html file is what we were looking at earlier, so we
just going to open that up, it will open up in your default browser.
>> Alright, but this is the game we made.
>> And now we have our images instead of the numbers.
>> And, this is, this game is actually much harder
when there's images.
>> because you don't know what's next.
>> Yeah, I don't know what numbers I'm doing, I just
know that I want the faces and so these are just
U.S. presidents. It's the first thing that came to mind, but
I mean, there's tons of cool things you can do and the
way I did this, was I went into the CSS file.
So we're in main.css and I went to all these places,
where it's talking about the actual tile properties. So, what is
the two tile look like, the four tile, and so on? And
I sort of just overrode the background,
I think this was referring to some color.
>> Yeah, so the original background was for
each of these a different color instead of.
>> Instead of an image.
>> Instead of an image. So, we actually, if
we were doing this for real, we'd probably want to remove
all those, all those backgrounds. I think Andy wanted
to be able to revert back if you wanted to.
>> I'm still not comfortable with versing control. I know you can just
do that on the fly but I kind of like doing this, I'm sorry.
But yeah so, I have, I made this folder called Tile Sets, Presidents and then
I just called the different images two, four, et cetera. And this dot,dot slash?
>> Mm-hm. So, what's going on here if I'm, tell me
if I'm thinking about this right. Index.HTML lives somewhere in my computer.
>> Mm-hm. Yeah, inside this 2048 directory.
>> Okay, and so the dot dot means go back up
a directory. Yeah, because this, this style file that we're in is
under Style.
>> So it's going back to the directory.
>> So, we go back up 2048.
>> And then it found.
>> And then go to the tile-sets directory which is just under 2048.
>> Okay, and if you open that, that's where
you get our presidents and you have all those files.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool, now what are you going to do? I don't know.
>> I don't know. I don't know an answer.
>> Let's keep playing around.